[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whats of Prof welcome Walter welcome
Martin we staring again well that's part
of the equation but there's a reason why
we have to do it let's look at the
reason so we're going to talk about the
Sunday
proposal that it might be sooner than we
think yeah there's some interesting
things in the title or back background
screen well if you look at the
background screen you have your Doomsday
Clock ticking
away and you have the climate crisis
down
there and let's see where it takes us
yeah maybe the and the legislation that
will be implemented will come through is
correct that the socalled climate crisis
yes and the legislation will be it's
maybe not as far off as we think yes
let's open with a word of prayer our
heavenly father thank you again that we
can be here we ask again please that you
Enlighten our minds with the Holy
Spirits in working and that we can
deliver whatever message you have for
the viewers in Jesus name amen amen
so M what is the Sunday proposal all
about before we start with the Sunday
proposal let's look at the concept of
present truth what is present truth and
why is there such a thing as present
truth 2 Peter 1:12 says wherefore I will
not be negligent to put you always in
remembrance of these things though you
know them
and be established in present
truth present truth is not new
truth it is the
unfolding of all
truth so if you read your scriptures
everything is there what was Peter
referring to well what was the present
Truth at that time Jesus was the Messiah
yeah was he predicted in the scriptures
yes if they had done a diligent study of
scripture could have could they have
recognized him 100% did they recognize
him no the reason why it was in the
scriptures is so that they could
recognize all right but they didn't
recognize it but some people did
recognize it yeah and to them that was
present truth that which was predicted
that which was scriptural had now become
a
reality and therefore it is very
important to know what present truth is
or what the unfolding of predicted old
truth is all about that's true and it
has signs the same that they had when
they were looking for the Messiah there
were certain signs
pre precursive the coming all right now
if you have uh a truth
that gets covered
in garbage and mud and it gets buried
that doesn't make it any less truth
no then if it is
uncovered and the devil doesn't like it
to be uncovered can he then cover it up
again yes okay so let's say for example
uh righteousness by
faith righteousness by faith
is obviously what the scriptures write
about what Paul writes about that is his
main
concern that's what the whole book of
Romans is about right the relationship
between law and Grace we discussed it in
the book of Galatians the other day that
is
truth and then the world comes and
throws a lot of garbage on it and buries
it yeah and hopefully according to the
devil's mindset it stays buried yeah
then you get a Martin Luther who starts
digging he's very popular right
everybody loves him no unless they
discover present truth yes so
righteousness by faith in Luther's time
became present
truth although it had been present truth
in Paul's days already so here was
present
truth and it led to the split between
protestantism and Catholicism
and then the the time ravaged this
precious truth and today they have a
common Accord yeah which totally
destroys that present truth is it then
necessary to dig it up and and present
it as present truth again absolutely it
was an old truth right that's it but it
became a present truth you know that
that's the thing with
truth even in Genesis it started off
with truth yes truth gos carries on the
whole time and Truth never gets old if
you if it's discovered it's never old
okay so now let's say the
Sabbath the Sabbath is it present truth
it's present and it's but it comes a
long time now some people think it's
2,600 years old as we will see but in
naturual fact it comes from creation
right so that makes it 6,000 years old
more or less
give a give or take a few
[Music]
[Laughter]
months all right so there are many
precious truths contained in the word of
God but it is present truth that the
flock needs
now that's not new truth that is old
truth in new
settings uh wash off the
mud and sh line up the gold and put the
present truth in settings of
gold I've seen the danger of The
Messengers running off from the
important points of present truth to
dwell upon subjects that are not
calculated to unite the
flock and sanctify the soul Satan will
here take every possible advantage to
injure the
cause all right if you're going to talk
to Christians do you have to spend a lot
of time explaining that Jesus is the
savior no because they should know it
right exactly do they have to do you
have to tell them the whole time Jesus
loves them no no they know that Jesus
loves them it's it's very nice to hear
that Jesus Loves You this I know for the
Bible tells me so that's it read your
Bible and then you internalize that and
that only gets better that um knowledge
when you have a relationship with him
all right so now you have a relationship
with Jesus and you
know that he cares about you and he
loves you and he wants you to forgive
you but there is a condition which is
called repentance correct all right so
now if repentance is no longer required
and everything goes does repentance not
then become a present truth yes because
they're all on a on a Garden Path
leading to nowhere so then again like
you mentioned before garbage is on top
of it so now you have to clear it away
it has to and and what if you see the
danger
approaching and you know that someone is
not adhering to an ancient
truth then it has to become a present
truth if you want to warn that person
that there is a tsunami coming yeah
exactly so that is why it is important
that you dwell on present
truth that does not mean that you negate
old truth and on the contrary it
actually elevates old truth yes or puts
it in right settings
yes there are but few even of those who
claim to believe it that comprehend the
third Angel's message and yet this is
the message for this time it is present
truth now we did a whole series on the
Three Angels
messages and we did it because it is
present
truth now why is it essential because if
you do not Embrace this truth which is
ancient truth you will be found wanting
in the Judgment true so is it love to
present the present truth or is it a
rebuke that we should less best leave
alone now obviously if you care for
somebody you will loudly Proclaim this
Truth All right so you will trumpet the
present truth will it irritate some who
have buried it under a pile of mud very
much very much so but how few take up
this message in its true bearing and
present it to the people in its power
with many it has but little Force the
closing work of the third Angel's
message will be attended with a power
that will send the raise of the son of
righteousness into all the highways and
byways of life and decisions will be
made for God as Supreme Governor his law
will be looked upon as the rule of his
government is it a fact that the
churches have negated the law and put it
into the trash heap of History yep and
they the law along with all the
requirements that God actually requires
they've just covered up under a Gul of
so if the psalmist says oh how I love
thy law was he
deceived no no or if the Bible says thy
law is truth yeah does it now all of a
sudden become an untruth no but if it's
covered in garbage would you want to
clean it up polish it up and present it
as present truth exactly make it
prominent again is a part of the third
Angel's message definitely all right so
Martin present truth has to be preached
because salvation depends on it yeah it
doesn't mean that you don't believe the
other truths because without the other
truths this truth stand is not a
standalone truth it's part of a package
isn't
it so the gospel m message for this time
is comprised in the third Angel's
message which Embraces the messages of
the first and second Angel and which is
to be proclaimed everywhere for it is
present Truth All right so the present
truth is not only the third Angel's
message it Embraces the first and the
second Angel's message yeah now we did
the whole series we don't have to repeat
the series it's now going to be
available in a
package that can be handed out hopefully
like the leaves of autumn yes well we
can actually show the
viewers uh it's in a credit card format
format it's nice we've got the uh Three
Angels messages this is five whats Prof
uh episodes on here the one with the
character of God the Three Angels and
the the fourth Angel and the fourth
Angel so that is a package deal of the
meaning of the Three Angels messages in
the context of our time being let's say
highlighted as present truth exactly so
this is a a nice Evangelistic tool to
get to give to people and then when they
want more you start show it is a flash
drive and it just folds out you it there
and there you and then you have your
flash drive yeah and then the other one
that we've made is the series on
dwelling in the secret place of you and
your wife that beautiful series okay so
that's also in a little package now and
it's available in video and
audio and we want to as far as possible
give them away for free yeah as long as
the Lord supplies the funds to do that
we will end Endeavor to try and do that
that's it and that is present truth that
is present Truth for the times that we
are living in and Martin why are we
doing this one now it is to show that
this is not conjecture it is really on
the table now it is we we always talk
about it I mean how many times have
people said ah but you always talk about
the same subjects and we've also
mentioned it but it's because that's
present truth and it it seems like
people just just don't get it sometimes
you have to repeat the thing over and
over until it finally sinks in now if
the media can do it with a lie ex and
put it on the media until everybody
believes the lie why can't we do this
with the truth exactly let's take that
climate change for instance yes do you
think you're only going to hear climate
change once and then it's finished no
you're going to hear it over and over
until people swallow the lie and now we
want them to swallow the truth we want
them to SW the truth
correct so Martin US immigration updates
YouTube channel now all of these things
are somehow connected right of course
it's we've always said that they that's
why we do these things we're not and
I've mentioned it before we're not a
news agency but we're taking whatever is
happening in the news or out there and
putting it into perspective yes and see
how it fits the prophetic
scenario now people must be brought to
the point where they will Implement
something that is maybe considered
unconstitutional or whatever but it is
in the interests of the beast that's it
to have his
authority accepted
worldwide that's what he wants it will
go there mhm because because the Beast
has as its boss the dragon yes and the
dragon is the hater of Jesus Christ
because the dragon is the devil and what
does he hate
most Authority that's it and then is
also wrath against the remnant of the
seed of the um Church of course of of
course he will be wroth against them
because they keep the Commandments of
God and he refuses to keep them yeah
he's his watch word is do what thou Wilt
is the of the law I don't feel anything
for your Authority that's what he's he's
doing he's thumbing his nose at the
creator of the universe including
himself so here you have a problem so
now he wants his authority asserted so
he has to break down certain norms and
standards and maybe if comes so far that
there is a divide in the population that
some side with him and some don't he
will even push it to the point of War
yeah even Civil War he doesn't care as
long as he gets his
will we spoke about it the other
day if you think about it when you read
the spirit of Prophecy where Satan sits
and he has this awful smirk on his face
when he sees all of these destruction
and people suffer he he thinks it's a
wonderful thing so let's see what this
is all about a court ruling Monday also
paved the way for the feds to take down
razor wire but Texas has since added
more it prompted some calls for the
federal government to take over the
Texas guard and I would remind everyone
that uh the circumstances under which
the federal uh government can mobilize a
state's national are outlined in the law
right so that I'll leave that there but
I'm just not going to get into
speculations on any actions the
president's going to take at this time
Governor Greg Abbott said in an
interview Friday that Texas is prepared
for any conflict between state and
federal authorities the governor of
Texas Greg Abbott drafted a letter not
simply to the administration but to the
world and here's part of what it says
say the state of Texas has the authority
under the Constitution to quote protect
itself that Authority is the Supreme law
of the land and it supersedes any
federal statutes to the contrary and
then following very quickly 25 other
states with Republican Governors signed
a letter pledging their support to Texas
and its constitutional right to defend
itself and this country those states
include Ohio Florida Utah Nevada and
many others and then the Biden
Administration responded the
administration threatened these states
and particularly Texas with a quote
24-hour deadline to allow border patrol
to reopen the border and to take down
the barb wire clearly a collision course
what happens next can you envision a
scenario in which you would put armed
state employees On the Border instead of
the National Guard of Texas we do have
other armed state employees On the
Border as we speak right this minute and
there the Texas Department of Public
Safety as well as other law enforcement
officers as well as National Guard from
other states and you can be assured
there will be more National Guard from
other states and more law enforcement
officers within the state of Texas and
other states we have been invaded and we
have demanded support from the president
to safeguard our state and they have
refused to do so eight times and that
authoriz me to uh uh declare an invasion
under Article 1 Section 10 of the
Constitution to make sure that Texas is
going to be able to use every tool in
our Arsenal to defend our states o of
the couple of dozen Republican L States
who've pledged support for you um how
many do you think would send National
Guard to Texas I'll be shocked and
disappointed if almost all of them do
not and this is a fight for the future
of America and they all know it and so I
believe that they will all be in on
December I believe however that this
will all come to an end on January the
20th of next year because I believe a
new president will be sworn in a
president who will actually enforce the
immigration laws of the entire country
not just the Texas border so Martin this
is what we call A A sideline issue that
is developing right yeah yeah this is
like a brewing of something yeah it's
leading somewhere so here
are people and eventually hold
states that become disillusioned with a
particular direction that the federal
government is taking now is it only an
issue of uh the Border or is it also an
issue let's say of woke yes is it an
issue of the Divide between church and
state yeah yeah is it an issue of
declining
morality yep all right so this is
basically one of the issues that is now
permitted let's say to start boiling
that's it this is almost like the entry
wedge this is an entering wedge to get
the other ones they already agitated
with that in all 25 of those States in
any case so correct do they want to in
actual fact sweep away the liberal
agenda and Implement a more conservative
agenda not only for the sake of safety
of the people but also for the sake of
morality and getting back to something
that has
more let's say spiritual Roots yes
definitely and they will continually
fall back onto the founding fathers and
the Constitution that's a Christian
Nation okay so is this possibly even a
diversion from from Satan from Satan yes
to keep your eyes occupied there so that
eventually he can bring the whole
package across to you and you accept it
because you've become so fed up with
this one issue yes that you will accept
the other issue and the whatever it is
as well you see and like we've mentioned
before some people some players in this
might even not know the final agenda of
Satan I think they don't know it if they
don't know present truth they will not
see how this puzzle is coming together
and that's why it's so important because
the present truth that we bring now is
the one that they don't see they don't
see it yet and they believe that they're
doing this for God and they are sincere
in their belief yes
unfortunately in the future they will be
have to made a choice they will have to
uh if you go back in history and you
take the regulations that have come in
because of diseases that have manifested
and the legislation that has been
brought in it's a means to an end it's a
tool of the Beast so it was a
distraction
and it provided the impetus to introduce
things which will be of benefit to an
agenda in the future yeah so that's how
present truth works you have to look at
the
mud and see the
agenda otherwise you just see mud that's
the problem and then you stand on the
wrong side and you get mad at the wrong
people all right so we have a border
crisis in the United States of
America and we have another crisis in
Europe yeah and this crisis has to do
with many of the same issues liberal
agendas and climate change agendas
because now the climate change agenda
which is an agenda to reach a certain
point yeah which attacks present truth
true that has with it um legal
implications and financial implications
that touch your pocket so you know if it
goes so far that you're not allowed to
breathe because you're exuding CO2 then
it becomes a life and death issue but or
you have a nice carbon meter on your
breath so you have to take slow and not
so many breaths otherwise you pay tax on
it all right now let's say for example
we're going to look at it in a moment
let's say for
example they want you to be totally
dependent and they want to use something
as a tool to get you totally dependent
so what if they want to say to you we
don't want you to grow your own
vegetables because you then you're not
dependent well they won't say it like
that they'll just tell you you you
growing your own food is bad for the
rest of the people it's very bad for the
rest of the people now the people say
excuse me there's no logic in what you
are saying then you say to them but as
we will see in a moment
CO2 is more prevalent if you grow your
own cabbage than if someone else grows
the Cabbage for you yeah and do you say
ah of course that's logical it's brain
dead but nevertheless let's leave it at
that yeah that's true but you know the
sad thing is people swallow it up and
they accept it all right but is there
turmoil and anger and AG itation
involved whether it is a farming issue
or whether it is a border issue no it's
all agitation and is it is it
unhappiness with the status quo and the
State of Affairs and the way in which
governments are dealing with certain
issues true yes is that a modus of
barandi to bring about enforced change
oh for sure that's Oro UPA again Oro UPA
that's the way it operates and just
before I forget I didn't put it in but
but there was like always Jesuit theater
has prepared everybody for the the
Border thing for instance oh yes and
Civil War it has well just before we go
to this I was I remembered that there
was a movie that came out in 1997 a
satire movie that was named the second
Civil War and the things happening in
that movie was exactly what you see
happening on so it's it's like a
blueprint for what is happen so it's
Jesuit theater at its best like always
you know every time there's something
like this happening you go and see that
you were desensitized before correct so
any revolution in history that you go
back in since the
Reformation any of those revolutions if
you looked and dug hard enough you would
find the Jesuits behind it yeah I have
no doubt that the same applies to today
exactly all right so let's have a look
at some of the turmoils that are
happening in Europe with the farmers
[Music]
everywhere you look small and
mediumsized Farms being gobbled up by
these corporate Mega Farms because they
can't keep up anymore they can't comply
with these endless streams of
regulations that are coming down we're
seeing that in China now where these
giant mechanized corporate big
government controlled Mega Farms are
displacing all these little small Family
Farms that families have been farming
for for hundreds of years in some cases
longer they're moving them all off their
little plots of land and moving them
into these big horrific mega cities that
they have built and we're going to see
that all over the world with the
decimation of small farms so if they're
not bankr Ed by economic forces the
government itself will shut them
down well Martin this is an
international thing MH and not only in
France or in Holland that you have these
riots you have them all over you have
them in China we have them in Africa we
have them on our
doorsteps the same sort of story over
and over and they want people to move
into these 15minute mega cities and uh
be quiet and be happy and own nothing
yeah that's it's so 100% against what
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy
tells us all right now we always said
we're observers right that doesn't mean
we don't have an opinion no but we are
observers we just don't get involved in
the war except warning in terms of the
prophetic
profile would these things make you
angry too yeah of course right of course
because it's illogical oh there is no
logic in it so if the government says to
you you may not plant a
lce you asked why can't I plant a
letters because your letters produces
more CO2 than my letters you said but
that's ridiculous where do you come with
such idiotic arguments right it was I
I've said this many times it was like
when we had that full lockdowns I went
to the store because you're not allowed
to go for anything else than the
Necessities okay so I went to the store
and I wanted to buy seeds to plant no
there was a banner in front of it saying
this is non-essential products you
cannot buy it you couldn't buy nuts they
were non-essential until you said to
them but to us they are essential
because I don't eat your other stuff
that you put on the Shelf so of course
you this will agitate people it has to
but that's not the
point the point is that you must be
become angry yeah so that there can be a
synthesis somewhere along the line and
are you going to be fooled into becoming
angry yes because then if you get a
government or a government official that
speaks the language you want him to
speak you're going to goe along with it
oh you're going to love it you're going
to love it so if you have to choose
between the devil and the deep blue
sea eventually you say well give me the
devil at least he's talking my language
that's what they going to to do okay so
let's look at a a study that was done
and this is a redacted YouTube video
where they talk about this carbon
footprint from hom produced products
yeah uh here's a new study that suggests
that Urban Gardens have a higher carbon
footprint than conventionally grown
produce in this study research Gardens
like this one they're bad for the Earth
worse than conventional farming now why
this worries me is because when we see
globalists tell you what has a high
carbon footprint then they're signaling
to us what they're going to start
tamping down on I mean EOS side as a
word is becoming more is becoming better
known around the world and the concept
is generally Mass damage and destruction
of nature um but legally speaking um
what our organization and other
collaborators aim to do is to have this
recognized legally as a serious ious
crime because one of the issues that
sort of pervades all of this discussion
is that we have a kind of cultural very
grained habit of not taking damage to
Nature as seriously as we take damage to
people and property um and that I mean
you know if you're campaigning for human
rights at least you know mass murder
torture all of these things are serious
crimes but there's no equivalent in the
environmental space um and so and and
you know unlike a an international crime
like genocide that in involves a
specific intent with EOS side what we
see is actually what people are trying
to do what businesses are trying to do
is make money is you know is Farm is
fish is do all of these things that are
um you know producing energy and so on
um as well but what's what's missing is
the awareness and the conscience around
the side effects around the collateral
damage that happens with that but here's
another lady who says that yeah because
farming is so problematic just get used
to AI made food food a lot of our things
that what we can do is scarcity and we
have products which you can have make
via biology it's so that you can replace
or or augment natural products
especially with climate change making
them more difficult to produce the other
thing that you can use with AI is
increase your solution space so if you
love The The Taste and Aroma of vanilla
can we have something that's reminiscent
of that that is new to the world and
using AI to increase that solution space
that a human alone would would not be
able to do so that's something we're
we're definitely leveraging using
receptor biology data and millions of
data points there using our
understanding of taste and smell to
identify what can be new that's that can
help consumers to have Sustainable
Solutions that are also really you know
desirable
right now Martin if you look at these
two
ladies could you become hot under the
column Cal and collected Cal and collect
it now I've been looking at the media
and I've been looking at some of the
things where the people respond to what
these people are saying but we cannot
show them because the language wouldn't
allow us to show it it's just one
profanity after the others they are so
angered by it why are they so angered
because they don't see the agenda they
don't understand it they just see an
enemy
encroaching and the energy is a mindset
which According to some people is so
moronic that they can't deal with it but
I won't even go to the logic if you
think there is no logic it's not
supposed to be logic nothing so are they
dependent on food yes they are dependent
on food but
obviously if it's AI produced it must be
fine know but this lady that says that
farming is a criminal offense and
producing food is a criminal
offense I can understand why people say
this is so stupid that you cannot
believe that a human being can be that
stupid but is this poor person a product
of
indoctrination if you move in those
circles where you have these these
mindsets then uh eventually you become
convinced that the the LIE is a truth
for sure it's the same with climate
change mhm now now again let's make the
point this divide
yeah is not what it's all about we have
to reiterate it because now people will
come and say but they won't get away
with it that's fine what is the agenda
yes what is the alternative if you see
this wave coming towards you this wave
of nonsensical idiocy
if you see it coming towards you and you
you realize this wave is so big M it's
going to flood
you then you have to build a dam you
have to build a dam and you have to
build a barrier and the and what people
don't understand and that's what we try
to bring over is that the plan that they
have will seem right and will seem good
if you don't know the agenda of the
Dragon correct so let's say you have
this one one package and then you have
another package and this one package
says what they are saying is nonsense in
terms of this that that and the other
could this package include
things which can lead to your ultimate
demise but you prepare to accept it
because it is a barrier against the
other
one that's how the hegelian dialectic
works
yeah it's brilliant it's a strategy
exactly and it's Satan's strategy that's
what everybody should remember so let's
not get too excited about the soap boxes
no now the new chosen L leader of the
Netherlands he's going to bring in a
religious aspect as well because like
we've always said you cannot divorce any
of this eventually from religion all
right now we're going to show this and
there will be some people that will be
offended because we show it but again we
are saying
there's a point to it we are bringing to
the four what is the agenda and where it
is leading and what is the agenda behind
this and let's say you have two
religious systems
Christianity and you have
Islam Islam is very much involved in the
dos and
[Music]
don'ts and the laws against the don'ts
are pretty stringent
especially if you have the absolute
Islamic laws attached to it that if you
steal you lose your
hand yeah and uh you know this
mindset and in the Christian world this
mindset doesn't really exist so there is
this this uh animosity that is
developing not only to towards the
different religions but also to towards
the the antagonism that goes along with
it yeah for sure and me the the whole
Israel and Gaza didn't help this whole
scenario but there's something that this
man says that is going to
be very important in the future so let's
just look at it acknowledge that Islam
is an influential ideology that Fosters
hatred and Terror and as a result is not
compatible with the values of the
Netherlands close our borders right away
to Asylum Seekers and immigrants
originating from Islamic countries we
should withdraw from the shenen
agreement and reintroduce our own border
controls three Begin by dismantling
Islamic institutions like mosques start
by closing foreign funded mosques
including those that receive funding
from abroad and are under the authority
of dianette the Turkish Ministry of
religious Affairs and not us for lock up
anyone who threatens or uses violence or
Deport them from our country and if
necessary take preventive action against
those hundreds of supporters and
thousands of sympathizers of the
jihadist movement in the Netherlands and
five chairman request all schools
newspapers media to display a Muhammad
cartoon in order not to provoke but to
demonstrate that we never give in to
threats and violence and that we proudly
and firmly support our
freedom finally I have a message for all
those Muslims in the Netherlands who do
not respect our freedom our democracy
and our core values those who consider
the rules of the Quran more important
than our secular laws and there are many
of them 700,000 is revealed in the study
by professor cman and my message to them
is get lost depart to an Islamic country
then you can enjoy Islamic rules those
are their rules but not ours this is our
country not your country but our
country that's a very interesting speech
sure you won't actually think that that
comes from a a leader of a country yes
he's struggling to put together a a
government but the fact that he got so
many votes means that he is touching a
cord right yeah oh for sure now Martin
what's very fascinating to me is we have
our values you have your values you got
don't do what you want to do but don't
impose it on
us and the values in the Quran are not
our values and if the Quran says
something which is contrary to our
secular laws then he says then you must
get
lost right
yeah but let's replace the word Quran
with the Bible mhm our Traditions say
such and such and if your Bible
contradicts with our tradition then get
lost get lost is that a possibility oh
for sure we'll see what we're working
because this is exactly where it will
will go according to what the Bible and
spiritual prophecy says we will have the
people saying that you don't want to
adhere to our laws and it's biblical get
lost all right why are their core values
different from the others because
they're based on a CHR Christian system
mhm now that Christian system has been
taken over by tradition yeah and
tradition has covered up truth yes so
present truth must come to the four
again exactly and if you're going to
preach present truth and it contradicts
with tradition and their core values are
you going to be in the same trouble as
Islam yes I'm not defending Islam No but
that's exactly what's going to happen
and that's what I meant when I was
earlier saying that the people will
think that doing God a favor
because they will but that is not going
to be present truth it's going to be the
covered truth right so let's get it out
before it happens Yeah so basically it's
the news before the news this so that we
can look back at it and say I think we
said so all right Martin
so if you want to choose a particular
side then uh you have to get your your
people to come together on this issue
they have to be of one mind and the
other side will do everything in its
power to prevent it right mhm now in the
case of carry Lake that's a very
interesting story because they even
tried to bribe her mhm to stay out of
the race so that they can put their
individual in place even within the
Republican party yeah and uh of course
this will really heat up the pot and
people will either decide for the one or
the other so there's an agenda let's say
to channel and move people into a
particular mindset and somebody like
krie Lake who says I will not be
intimidated well that's something that
you can that you can appreciate right
and whose side is she on she's on
Trump's side so let's see where this
goes so the manipulation is absolutely
amazing the manipulation and probably we
never know but there can also be an
agenda there can be an agenda let's have
a look you know sometimes
Martin negative
advertising is the best advertising that
you can get I've I've experienced it in
my own life when the leadership comes
out and says do not attend those
lectures they are from the evil one then
you can be pretty sure the whole will be
full so I'm very grateful for all those
leaders who always rile against what uh
we sometimes have to say and that's just
says two years as well yes it happens
the same the more they give negative
things about Trump the more it seems
that he he's
Rising what you're about to hear is the
Arizona GOP party chairman Jeff dwit
talking to Carrie Lake about how someone
back East wants her to drop out and is
willing to pay her big money to do it
trying to probe how much it will take to
get her out and someone else in who
someone who who can be controlled
someone who's not Maga someone who will
do so this imaginary sort of party boss
I mean there is somebody even DT seems
to be admiss admitting this is not a
madeup thing uh to do that person's
bidding who this is Back
East they there are very powerful people
that want to keep you out they do but
they're willing to put their money with
their mouth is in a big way so
this conversation never had if you if
you say no which just fine it's your
choice don't tell people I they're going
to have try to have me
murdered okay Martin so let's just look
at this from this from the side of
manipulating
Thinking by airing something like this
and making it prominent will you get
some people to make even a more firm
decision to choose one side over another
side yes definitely so would something
like this in the case of trump favor him
or make it worse for him no definitely
favor him so if you want to make
somebody uh more prominent how about 10
court cases against him yeah for sure
have they done anything to pull him down
maybe in some circles but generally
speaking he his uh shares seem to be
rising now you see the thing is just
that fact makes him seem like an
outsider and makes him people give more
respect almost so that even people
that's on the Democrat side or even
people that don't they say okay but he's
not part of this establishment he's like
a a lone wolf yeah now let's again
reiterate it doesn't really matter
exactly this is all part of the
game the the thing that does matter is
what comes with the ideological package
of those that will be in
power is church and state going to be an
issue no for sure absolutely right it's
the part of this whole thing okay if it
were the Democrats would it be an issue
from the other side yes to keep it apart
yes okay Martin let's move this
discussion in the direction of moral
issues obviously everything that we've
said so far also has a moral application
or a moral
implication so let's look at morality
and how important is it to the people in
this world how important would it be to
the people in this world that the moral
issue also be
addressed now Elon Musk has this neuro
think where they're actually
implanting chips into the
brain and let's just see what the
discussion is about on that issue Elon
Musk he put up a post a few hours ago on
Twitter now known as X and this is what
he said the first human received an
implant from neuralink yesterday and is
recovering well initial results show
promising neuron Spike detection he says
the first product is called telepathy
it will allow you to control your phone
or computer just by
thinking and through them you can
control other devices if it works it
could be a GameChanger especially for
people with some form of paralysis they
could benefit immensely from a
technology like this musk says they will
be the first
recipients here's what he wrote and I'm
quoting imagine if Steven Hawking could
communicate faster than a speed typist
or Auctioneer that is the goal because
helping people without limbs is just the
beginning he eventually wants an
advanced brain computer
interface imagine driving a smart car
with just your thoughts or playing video
games with your mind or accessing all
the information on the internet through
your brain imagine someone hacking your
brain
chip reading your thoughts controlling
your robotic
limbs it's a terrifying Prospect
and someone will likely manage to do it
so we need to be
cautious so M this is something that can
be very
positive and it can be very
negative do you think there is a power
in this world that would love to hack
your brain oh for sure do you think
there's a power in this world that might
want to reprogram your brain he's very
hard at work in different ways to try
and do that all right is there power in
this world that would like to modulate
your religious thinking
MH yeah you can see that in the
propaganda
okay so Elon musk's neuralink raises
questions about how modal future humans
might
be so how model will the future humans
be it just announced that neuralink a
brain computer interface had been
implanted into a human brain for the
first time our cognitively Advanced
future cousins May stand in relation to
us as we stand in relation to our dogs
better able to appreciate moral nuances
that escape us because of our cognitive
inferiority dumbfounded in the face of
model
considerations that at our current
cognitive level simply do not click but
here's the thing none of this would
actually make us more moral the boosted
IQ the sharper memory the greater
appreciation of moral concerns none of
it the reason is simply merely
understanding morality does not make you
morally
better
Martin is the world moving in very
strange direction oh I don't think
people can argue that anymore now can AI
be moral no it can can be programmed to
be to have a moral thinking according to
the program so it can have a morality
that is subject to the status quo of
tradition yeah that's it so AI can
decide what is right and what is wrong
and you could say that is morality yeah
is that what god did did he program you
totally the opposite isn't that the
beauty about God oh for sure
he do you know I always I always
Marvel at the
thought that God was prepared to
die for your freedom of choice
yeah in actual fact the mindset that God
has is therefore
diametrically opposed to whatever the
mindsets in the world out there these
control freak mindsets yeah no it's it's
unfathomable I mean he died to give you
the choice that you can hate him all
right now does this mean that God
doesn't have a moral compass of what
is's right and what is wrong of course
not he has a moral compass and he wants
you to come to the conclusion that that
is the only logical one to
assume but he gives you a choice as to
whether you want it or not now choice is
a bit of of a rock in a hard place mhm
because if you choose against it it
means that you will not be part of it by
your own choice yeah yeah but but we've
discussed that
before but this is all very fascinating
so where are we heading we're heading
towards a a mindset which says human
morality is very important MH and there
is no morality that we can really see in
the world anymore we need to go back
that's very good and logical thinking
unless there's a catch to it that's
where it gets dangerous and this brings
us to the issue of the Sabbath yeah and
the Three Angels messages the third
angel in the context of the first and
second angels and then eventually the
loud Cry of the angel of Revelation
chapter
18 now Martin these articles are brand
new yeah they are
2024 they are not
old so this whole issue of the debate
round about a day of rest yes it's has
become important so much so that it is
now a moral issue mhm so here's an
article from caf Sabbath for this year
and beyond for this year and Beyond now
please note we're not saying that it
will happen this year no but but these
are suggestions and and it's starting to
pick up Tempo ah okay so let's see what
these articles say keeping Sabbath in
the productivity obsessed culture of the
United States is
absolutely a countercultural
practice and it's completely possible
even for the busiest people is that
planting an idea definitely okay you
know intellectually the importance of
taking time off but haven't been able to
connect the dots in my work as a coach
for women in Ministry I do just that
connect what you think you should be
doing with a pathway to actually
creating the rest that restores the soul
creating Sabbath practices that stick is
not about finally getting more organized
or figuring out how to get people to
stop texting you on that day off what
I'd offer instead are four principles to
change your
thinking you can create the Sabbath rest
you need when you unwind and rewire the
habitual thinking driving you to work
more than you want he's talking very
generally about Sabbath but obviously
Ministry is involved so this would be
Sunday keeping for
sure so is he planting the idea that we
should actually do this yeah definitely
that is the main thing and maybe we can
just give a disclaimer a lot of the
things that these articles say is very
good yes it's definitely very good but
like we said said
the dragon has an agenda yes it's based
on a false premise yes the authority of
the Beast versus the authority of God
this is like you mentioned this is the
truth that's covered rest and if you
don't keep the Sabbath then it's
countercultural yeah countercultural
practice like we mentioned then you're
not loving your neighbor so the 25th of
January was a present for
me to show that the world is really
moving towards
Sunday and I want to go home so thank
Time magazine for doing
this but now I'm scared that you're
going to start Implement what they say
here no no no no this is all part of the
package so they said rest takes hard
work Americans have long been known for
our industry and ambition but until
recently we also recognized the value of
rest the Puritans had a famously strict
work ethic but they also took their
Sunday very
seriously but irrespective of who is
writing these articles and irrespective
of their
convictions what is interesting to me is
the flood that is coming
in so that the people will obtain this
mindset oh for sure you see while the
devil is working hard to push his agenda
God's purpose will never be lost so in
all of this if the the people are truly
seeking they will still find the truth
they will find it yes they have to find
it because it's it's a matter of life
and death that they do find it again
then he talks about 1842 Henry David
too the really efficient laborers will
be found not to crowd his day with work
but will saunter to his task surrounded
by a wide Halo of ease and Leisure a
decade later he wrote a broad margin of
leisure is as beautiful in man's life as
in a book post Civil War captains of
industry didn't rise and grind according
to business journalist Bertie Charles
Forbes no man goes in more
wholeheartedly for sport and other forms
of recreation
than industrialist Coleman Dupont while
Teddy rifel boisterously enters into
Recreation despite A busy life at the
same time Union organizers mass media
and entertainment and the parks movement
democratized Leisure rest became a right
enshrined as much in college sport and
Penny arcades as in labor
law so what they ADV ating for is a day
of rest that's it they throw in the
example of Sunday rest I find it
interesting that the Supreme Court in
the United States of America is blurring
the distinction between church and
state and saying if something has a
secular component that's it yeah then
it's not only a religious component and
therefore doesn't fall unto this article
that church and state should be
separated and Sunday of course then has
to have a secular reason as well so now
it already has like we see here college
sport Penny arcades and climate change
and climate change that's why we have a
polar bear there on our backdrop because
it will be one of the means it'll be one
one of the means and because there's a
secular component now as well then the
Supreme Court can rule if it should get
to that point
that it's not a conflict of interests
yes here's an article from Fox News from
the 2nd of January in a New Year Pastor
reveals how to get back to church every
Sunday a prayerful decision so let's
bring in a a very religious aspect which
according to the Constitution should not
be part of the package but if it has a
secular component then it can be part of
the pack very clever um it's brilliant
it's brilliant why are so many people
reluctant to go to church these days and
should I say anything about it to them a
pastor in Washington is weighing in for
those who desire to return to church
again on a regular basis in the new year
of
2024 when do they want it now now they
want it now or who have friends or
family members in that position people
who perhaps have held back since the
covid-19 p pandemic or even
earlier at this holiday time of the year
said pastor Jesse Bradley of Orban
Washington people are especially
appreciative of and receptive to
attending church services with
others attending a church service in
person is ideal and is a different
experience than just watching a service
online church is a place where there
should be Hospitality truth inspiration
and a chance to serve others and use
your talents too he basically saying
please make Sunday available to all yeah
so that's why I say you these people are
probably most probably sincere yes and
it's good points and is he given a
platform oh for sure Fox News Fox News
gives him a platform
so is it in Fox news's interest to push
this point yeah because aren't the
evangelicals part of the voting package
that go along with getting rid of that
tsunami that's coming along yep okay so
here is a something that's added to the
package there an article from The
Washington Post from January the 3rd
2024 why are all these articles coming
all of a sudden in the same month yeah
at the beginning of
2024 don't get me wrong we're not time
setting we're not saying something will
happen in
20124 no it's just showing you that
different places Washington Post New
York uh um Fox News Time Magazine all of
them every Friday around Sunset I close
my laptop for 24 hours my work is done
NOA email no news this person is
actually keeping the true Sabbath Friday
evening he's closing it
off the the dichotomy is just amazing to
me but it'll swing to Sunday by default
that's it project 2025 project 2025 says
by default it will be
Sunday not in the beginning necessarily
just everybody just keep your Sabbath
according to what you want no social
media if it's work rated it waits for
Millennia religions have regarded this
ritual rest as a spiritual
necessity yet clergy are now arguing
that this practice whether secular or
religious context can help redirect the
world societies away from catastrophic
climate change and that's where your
problem lies now you have a secular
reason why Sunday can be legisl
Martin this is incredible all in one
month there's an agenda by the way do
all these news
outlets belong to certain individuals
and are these individuals controlled
well I'll ask it with another question
can we write an article and they'll put
it in there I doubt whether they
will maybe in the future to condemn us
yeah yeah well that's the only reason
all right now we've shown many of times
where the various news organizations in
the world repeat word for word the same
thing that sounds like synchronized
thinking don't they want a synchronized
day of rest oh for sure this is the new
watch word a synchronized day of rest
they don't want just a day of rest
synchronized because then the family
comes together that's good for the
family
it has a religious connotation because
you can go to church but if it's good
for the family that's a secular reason
and clate again like you said so you've
got all this family climate we don't
really have to read it all no he's just
also what I found interesting is's also
reiterating what we've said that Sunday
keeping is incon in a doubt to see maybe
you can just read that part all right so
it's interesting that he says the s
abbath is the day on which we learn the
art of surpassing civilization Pope
Francis argued much the same about
Christianity Sunday in his 2015 latu SE
and encyclical about caring for the
natural world not resting is not just
bad for the soul he says but it is bad
for the
Earth it's a brilliant strategy but it's
deceptive and it's based on a liee yeah
Martin in in the light of all these
articles coming out in all of these very
prominent news
Medias do you think it would be
appropriate for the Catholic Church to
give its two cents towards the argument
as well no for sure they have to they uh
claim Sunday for themselves obviously
they will have something to say all
right so it's interesting that on the 30
of January
2024 the Catholic news agency came out
with this article the Sabbath or the
Lord's Day Reviving an ageold
argument and providing lame arguments
which can
easily be disputed by just reading the
Bible but let's go through it
anyway recently we received an 80 P
booklet entitled what's behind the new
world order it admits to be a collection
of excerpts from the book will America
survive which was originally published
100 years ago under the title The Great
controversy Martin is the issue of
Sunday
worship going to become prominent well
you can see it it is going to become
prominent and the Seventh Day Adventist
Position will it be placed in jux the
position to the world view 100% And The
agitation of the spirit of Prophecy that
brings to the four who is the Beast and
what is the mark of the beast will be
agitated and we will see that here we
have it the book The Great controversy
which I believe everybody in the whole
world should read
y this book was written by EG white
foundress of the seventh day
Adventists is this denomination being
made prominent here for sure singled out
and standing against who against the
Beast against Roman
Catholicism and it's not us just saying
it's the Beast let's remind people that
the entire Protestant world before this
modern era believed that the Roman
Catholic system was the Beast it is
absolutely biblical that it was the
Beast it claims the Catholic church is
behind the New World Order the booklet
claims that this is true since the
church is the Beast of Revelation
chapter
17 according to the booklet one mark of
the Beast is not observing the Sabbath
on
Saturday well maybe we can just stop
there that's not what that booklet says
the great controversy makes it very
clear that that's not this one says one
mark of the beast no the mark of the
beast let's make it clear is Sunday it
is Sunday keep not observing the Sabbath
on Sat not observing the Sabbath on
Saturday no because that could be any
other day then the mark of the beast is
Sunday
it is alleged that in the fourth Century
the church and Emperor
Constantine replace the Sabbath with the
Pagan day of the sun wasn't their own
documents say this yeah I.E Sunday now
it is true that the Old Testament says
the seventh day but assigning that to
Saturday is Hebrew tradition yeah so
it's a Jewish sabbath right but what
happened in at creation Mar if you just
look in a
dictionary then you see that Saturday is
the seventh day of the week wow that is
only if you look at the good
dictionaries because we showed even some
modern ones change it all right some
modern ones change it but if you take
language for example it's pretty clear
that in most languages Saturday is
Sabbath sabat that's it and if you take
German then the middle of the week is
mitv middle of the week is
Wednesday mitv middle of the week then
unfortunately Sabbath is the seventh day
Saturday they really have no leg to
stand on here it is a lame argument
as Christians we must consider this in
the light of the New Testament and the
teachings of Christ if this is a mark of
the beast almost all Christian churches
today bear the mark too stop
there only if you are put before the
choice under legislation and
force and you choose the mark of the
beast over the Mark of God the sign of
God which is the Sabbath then you
receive the mark of the beast and yes
they are right the entire Christian
world is following their lead and they
need to be warned that's what the Three
Angels messages is all about so they're
actually acknowledging where the Bible
says and the whole world wondered after
the Beast
correct it is ironic that Jesus and his
disci disciples were harassed by the
Pharisees over the Sabbath Jesus spoke
out against the Pharisees merciless
merciless observance of the Sabbath
Jesus also defended himself and his
disciples on this issue by saying the
Sabbath was made for man not man for the
Sabbath so the son of man is Lord even
of the Sabbath now the Ridiculousness of
this argument is that these people want
to enforce their Sunday but they are
saying that the
enforc the rules for that particular day
now what Jesus was talking against is
their Traditions which they added you
were not all allowed to walk a th meters
more than a th000 meters on a Sabbath
day thousand
steps you had to not eat an egg that was
laid on the Sabbath etc etc they had
thousands of nonsensical
rules and Jesus showed that their
Traditions were of no effect true but he
honored the Sabbath yes the in the way
it was supposed to in the way it was
supposed to be so this argument again is
a lame
argument they continue to say it is true
that the Catholic Church through the
authority of Christ replaced the Hebrew
Sabbath Saturday with the Lord's day
Sunday that is a blatant lie well it's a
blasphemy actually actually because the
previous verse that they quoted said
that Jesus is Lord of the Sabbath yes
and here they say but Jesus gave them
the authority to change it to Sunday
where did he give them that Authority
when he did he give it to them when he
said not one jot or one p will by any
means disappear of the out of the law or
did he say it to them when they said
pray that you don't flee on the Sabbath
all right and what about the disciples
that rested on the Sabbath day according
to the commandment and then very early
on the first day of the week went to
continue their work of bringing the
spices to embal the body of Jesus so the
argument is lame and futile and
blatantly a lie they receive no such
Authority on the contrary they are
condemned by the scriptures if they
touch the law of
God however this occurred very early
well before the time of emperor
Constantine in the 4th Century for
Christians two important events happened
on Sunday first the resurrection of
Christ occurred on Easter Sunday
secondly the Holy Spirit descended upon
the church on Pentecost Sunday and after
his resurrection Jesus appeared to the
apostles twice each on Sunday as a
result Sunday became known as the Lord's
day for Christians
excuse me the only time that the that
the Bible speaks about the Lord's
Day in the context of a specific day is
in the book of
Isaiah where it says about the Sabbath
to keep the Lord's Day honorable yeah
now when they refer to the Lord's Day in
the Book of
Revelation John says I was in Vision on
the Lord Lord's day but he doesn't say
what day that was so they are implying
that it was Sunday exactly without one
biblical injunction to do so true so
there again they are not in harmony with
scripture the booklet claims that there
is no evidence in the Bible for the
shift to Sunday however in the 4th
Century St John chisom cited acts 27 as
testimony
uh excuse me so now St John became the
authority yes he became the authority
not the word of God according to this
verse in the Bible at least some of the
disciples assembled together on Sunday
the first day of the week to celebrate
the Lord's Supper that's ridiculous they
came together to break bread together
and then it says in the other place they
came together every day to break bread
together they were eating it Simply
Having a meal together nothing to do
with their Eucharistic celebration which
is Pagan by the way because it is a
symbol of baale there round wafer Sun
God on the first day of the week when we
were gathered together to break bread
Paul talked with them acts
20:7 so they're misapplying that verse
yeah John John said no this can be
applied to show that it was moved to
Sunday yes
it is interesting to note that St Paul
had spent a week with the community in
traz and this is the only reported time
that he celebrated the breaking of bread
with
them already in the Old Testament God
expresses disappointment of the Hebrew
Sabbath in the New Testament Paul writes
therefore let no one passed judgment on
you in questions of food and drink or
with regard to a festival or a new
or a Sabbath now there's something
basically very wrong here in what they
are saying it is true that it is a
Sabbath but it should be lowercase
Sabbath because what they're referring
to here of course is the ceremonial
sabbaths which have nothing to do with
the Sabbath yeah with the weekly one new
translations make it the Sabbath which
is a blatant lie and a distortion again
so they are basing their facts
on
manuscript
interpretations which are false and once
again the Shadows the moral law of the
Ten Commandments was never a shadow y it
was never a shadow of things to come the
the Sabbath points back to Creation not
to the ministry of Christ which were the
shadow laws according to these verses
the Hebrew diet festivals and sabbaths
are no longer obl ations for the
Christians which is absolute nonsense
because the moral law says nothing about
diet it is only the ceremonial law that
says something about diet so here we
have such a goly goop of information and
a distortion of scripture if you want to
know what the Bible says then you have
to read it as it
stands these were only foreshadowing of
things to come in Christ the Focus now
is Christ elsewhere St Paul told the
Corinthians to contribute money to the
church each Sunday this would be a
strange request if Christians assembled
on
Saturday here again they are
misinterpreting what the scripture says
just as they misinterpret what happened
at tros yeah it was on the first day of
the week that they came together at
trows and the Bible says there were many
lights in the room so it was evening
that means it was after the Sabbath had
ended yeah Saturday evening so why did
he do that because they kept the Sabbath
and they had their meeting as to what
was going to go what was going to take
place on the first day of the week in
other words they came together after the
Sabbath on Saturday evening on Saturday
evening to discuss things that's why
there were lights in the room and that's
why poor uus was tired because it was in
the evening and that's why Paul preached
until the morning and he preached until
the morning which was Sunday morning and
then he went on a long journey so they
never kept Sunday it's absolutely
ridiculous and the same here Paul didn't
want them to calculate on the Sabbath
day what the tithe portion was so he's
actually elevating the Sabbath by doing
correct and he says to them
calculate these things and put the money
aside on a Sunday and when I come I will
collected from you so it wasn't a church
meeting at all he was telling you to put
the tithe money aside on the first day
of the week so let's get this scenario
you get paid on the Friday you're a
weekly earner before Sabbath don't
bother with calculating things and uh
destroy desty the sanctity of the
Sabbath after Sabbath do your
calculation put the money aside it's not
a church service because when I come
back I will collect it and give it
to the disciples for distribution that's
how it worked so every single argument
that they use is contrary to what the
Bible is actually
saying the point is
this are they arguing in favor for the
Sunday 100% all over the whole time
they're justifying why the Sunday is
important basing it on non-biblical
principles verily my sabbaths you shall
keep so the Old
Testament was totally wrong when it
spoke about the Sabbath and God was so
unhappy with the Sabbath that he changed
to the Sunday well you can see in the
beginning at the top of this article God
expressed this disappointment over the
Hebrew
Sabbath it's so pathetic that it really
needs to be exposed so uh let's
continue if Saturday were truly carved
in stone then it would be strange to
speak of another day according to
Revelation 1:10 St John was in the
spirit on the Lord's day this is the
only place in the Bible where the phrase
the Lord's day occurs sorry wrong again
it occurs in Isaiah M where it talks
about the Sabbath Saturday as the Lord's
day but you see that is the one that
they put on on top there and say Isaiah
1:3 is the disappointment that the Lord
had over the Hebrew
Sabbath now the essential point of the
third commandment wrong again exactly
the Sabbath is the fourth Commandment
they removed the second one because they
want their Idols in their church and
they want to bow down to their statues
so again they've got the Commandment
wrong even the number it is the fourth
Commandment that is the Sabbath is that
we said one day a week holy to the lord
well then why are they arguing for
Sunday if any day will do yeah why you
should sit on it what about Saturday
then so what they accuse you of of
wanting to keep the seventh day they are
in fact guilty of by wanting to enforce
the
Sunday but specifically observing
Saturday as this day is only
ceremonial Martin why would God put the
Sabbath in the modal law inside the
ark why would he do that if it was only
ceremonial the ceremonial law was placed
outside the ark yeah the sabbaths and
the ceremonial law was to be fulfilled
in Christ and therefore no longer
literally kept so this is a total
Distortion it is
misleading it is a false premise these
are false guides false
teachers they are wolves in sheep
clothing but the majority of the
Christian world has the same arguments
about this Sunday they used the same
argument and where did they get it from
they got it from the Roman Catholic
church so as baptism replaces
circumcision for chrisan
so does Sunday replace Saturday where
does it say so in scripture No there
tradition tradition says so observance
of the Lord's day is not a mark of the
beast but the mark of being a Christian
no it is the mark of the beast it is a
Roman Catholic institution and they
blatantly say in other articles that the
Protestants have no argument for their
Sunday keeping it is based on a law of
the Catholic Church alone their own
writings condemn them and here they want
to sanctimoniously Twisted around and
lie to the people outside will be where
all the Liars
are so there is this massive drive to
get people back to rest either for a
secular reason but also for this
religious reason and they want to get
them back to church because they want to
get the morality back into the into the
system so here's another janry article
that came out this year and this one
argues as to why you should attend
church in person on a Sunday and they
say show up to stir up gather to make it
the last day gather to evangelize the
Lost gather to display God's glory to
the universe gather to declare Christ
and equip people we want you there
physically is there an agitation for
Sunday keeping it's a drive from all
avenues okay so we're heading for
something right another article from
janary isn't it amazing that they all
come out in January as if 2024 must be a
preparatory year for getting these
things back into the
system Sabbath for all creation Sabbath
has an image problem today Sabbath often
conveys overwhelmingly negative ideas
don't do that especially if it's
enjoyable how far is this from God's
plan for Sabbath it is meant to be
joyful celebration for very goodness of
all creation so let's link creation to
the Sabbath which is correct you see
that's what I say this is some of the
points are very good yes the points are
good but the day is wrong they is wrong
and then it becomes you can see the
total counterfeit and they're saying
it's a foraste of Eternity Jesus rose
from the same arguments then it goes to
Sunday then it goes to Sunday so let's
keep Sunday so the thing is you out of
creation comes the true Sabbath yes now
because of climate change you want to
restore this false thing with Sunday
you've got a a gobbly GOP you have a lie
attached to a truth
so here's an article from eternity that
came out in late December
2023 and it said Sabbath as restoring or
restoring in other words what they are
implying is let's give it a new story
let's give it a faft yeah yeah make it
attractive again make it attractive okay
so the problem with Sabbath is not that
it fails to
restore but that many don't take one one
day in seven off and over the long term
suffer from their delusional conviction
that their work could never get along
without them for Christians the first
day of the week is Sunday Martin are you
a Christian yes what does the Sabbath
law say the fourth Commandment says that
no isn't it the third
commandment not according to the Bible
okay according to the Bible the fourth
Commandment says remember remember the
Sabbath day which is the seventh day
okay and the disciples rested according
to the Commandment it says in the New
Testament right and blessed are they
that do his
Commandments and he Jesus said I've not
come to destroy the law of the prophets
not one jot or one title will by any
means be removed from the law and then
he warns any one who changes one of the
least of these Commandments is condemned
right yeah
is the Sabbath the least of The
Commandments or is it the most important
one because it shows you who the
authority of the law is behind the law
is interesting stuff think about this
now look at this argument it's very
fascinating we take the first day of the
week off to rest does this person know
that Sunday is the first day
yep sounds out doesn't it surely we
should take the last day off when we are
exhausted and flustered
when we have worked hard enough to earn
a break ah but Sunday Sabbath observance
pushes in a different direction you get
the gift of a day before you have earned
anything and that day is Resurrection
Day now how twisted can you be that's a
thing if you read Genesis what was the
reason you had Sabbath partake in the
completed works of God and have rest
with him now they Twisted totally around
they Twisted totally around so if you
take rest in God
does that include accepting
righteousness by faith yes because you
are resting from your labors to strive
to get to heaven so you're not keeping
the law as a means but if you love him
you keep them as a
consequence this is evil it is such a
distortion sounds so good but it sounds
so good but it's packaged in a way to
deceive
you see the problem is this sounds so
good that even us speaking and saying
that this is twisted and everything
people will come up and say to you
you're an enemy you're an enemy why
don't you just the the people are
meaning good they love God just accept
let them be all right another article
January 7 I know we're laboring the
point we're showing but they're all
coming out this year in January mhm God
God created the world in six days and on
the seventh day he rested it was the
seventh day that he made holy why why
don't they remember that yeah why did
this is a reversal of values of
Americans we value work although we
complain about it and we see rest as a
lost opportunity for work the seventh
day God called the Sabbath and one he
made holy the holy day is the day his
people rested Martin why don't they
believe that he was so protective of
this day of rest that he made its
violation punishable by death I get it
the Sabbath was part of a Jewish
ceremonial law he blows his foot
off while it was designated as a day of
rest it was intended to be a Sabbath to
the Lord it is sad that God had to
legislate a day of rest for the
Israelites but he knows how we humans
are you are not a Jew and you live under
the Testament rather than the Covenant
but you need to see the wisdom in
rest Twisted right round you see the
problem is the people are
lost have an anchor yeah you have to
make up this whole thing just not to
adhere to exactly what the word says on
keeping the Sabbath on the seventh day
now just look at that last verse this is
really interesting how people argue and
think they didn't have a covenant
the Covenant was for the
Jews but I thought the Lord was going to
make a new covenant and that Covenant
was to write the law in the heart so is
the law gone no it's the Covenant gone
no the only difference between the Old
Testament is that it became a system of
Works to receive Merit it was a wrong
way of thinking God wanted to set
thinking straight and he said I will
write that same law that you are keeping
as a means to Salvation I'll write it in
your heart that you will keep it as
gratefulness because of Salvation that
was the difference but they twist it
right round so M let's get to a point
here there is a massive agitation to
start
introducing Sunday mhm right yeah and
the pressure is on the arguments are on
the table the Roman Catholic Church
stepped in with their article defending
the Sunday and pointing out seventh day
Adventists as the adversary to this idea
yes is it on the table it's in the
public eye now it's in the public eye
now when the pressure mounts and
government starts making
laws and as that Dutch gentleman said if
you at
our secular laws by
your supposed standard whether it be the
Quran he never mentioned the Bible but
it could go that way the secular law
stands then anybody who wants to keep
the true Sabbath will come into conflict
with the
law right is it
possible that the
churches that even Advocate Sabbath like
like the seventh day Baptists or the
seventh day
Adventists that they could come under
imen pressure oh for sure they will have
to yes for sure all right now what
happened last time when governments
placed pressure on the churches to
violate conscience did they side with
government or with freedom of conscience
freedom of conscience isn't that a very
sad State of Affairs do you think it'll
happen again it will it will bring about
persecution as well okay so do you think
even within our own ranks many will jump
onto the Sunday bandwagon to save their
skins I'm sure you see the problem is
that it will be so well disguised like
we've showed in these articles that they
will stand up and say no but you must
just love those Brothers all right now
in the spirit of Prophecy there is a
little bit of advice as how to deal with
it and it says there a wise course to
pursue to defy the Sunday
laws will but strengthen in their
persecution the religious zealots who
are seeking to enforce them give them no
occasion to call out call you law
Breakers if they are left to rain up men
who fear neither God nor man the
reigning up will soon lose its novelty
for them and they will see that it is
not consistent nor convenient for them
to be strict in regard to the observance
of Sunday
all right this is how it's going to
start they're going to make a Sunday day
of
rest now is there anything wrong Martin
with worshiping God on a Sunday no just
because there's a Sabbath in the Bible
no no I can worship him on any day for
sure but the day of rest is on a
Saturday that's it whether we like it or
not so the Sabbath is on a Saturday on
it you shall not do any work that's a
law of God now the Sunday is just a
normal secular day which has been made
Holy by the Catholic church and they
tell you to keep Sunday I have no
problem yeah doing whatever they want me
to do on a Sunday as long as they don't
force me to violate the seventh
commandment by working on a
Saturday so while there are only Sunday
laws but not yet anti- Sabbath
laws it should be fine to do what the SP
of Prophecy says over here exactly for
instance but I have a question what
about
forced
Sunday
observance well Martin if they force you
to worship God and and go to church on a
Sunday then have a church service on
Sunday let's read what it says here I I
agree keep right on with your missionary
work with your Bibles in your hands and
the enemy will see that he has was
worsted his own cause one does not
receive the mark of the beast because he
shows that he realizes the wisdom of
keeping the Peace by refraining from
work that gives offense doing at the
same time a work of the highest
importance when we devote Sunday to
missionary work the whip will be taken
out of the hands of the arbitrary
zealots who would be well pleased to
humiliate Seventh Day
Adventist when they see that we employ
ourselves on Sunday in visiting the
people in opening the scriptures to them
they will know that it is useless for to
try to hinder our work by making Sunday
laws Sunday can be used for carrying
forward various lines of work that will
accomplish much for the Lord on this day
open air meetings and cottage meetings
can be held that's almost like going to
church isn't it it's the same house toh
house work can be done those who write
can devote this day to writing their
articles whenever it is possible let
religious Services be held on Sunday now
Martin is this saying violate the
Sabbath law that's what I want to
reiterate or make prominent this is not
saying okay go along with their plans if
they say to you you cannot keep Sabbath
now let's say you get a conforming
Seventh Day Adventist or even some of
the leaders saying but she said we can
switch to Sunday could they distort this
and say that I'm sure they will I'm sure
they will they did very well with the
last crisis they might do equally well
with this crisis I'm not saying all of
them no but I'm sure we will see this
article again yes make these meetings
intensely
interesting sing genuine Revival hymns
and speak with power and Assurance of
the savior's love speak speak on
Temperance and on true religious
experience that the teachers in our
school devote Sunday to missionary
effort I was instructed that they would
thus be able to defeat the purposes of
the enemy let the teachers take the
students with them to hold meetings for
those who know not the truth thus they
will accomplish much more than they
could in any other way now the
interesting point here
is this will only work
while the law is propagating Sunday but
once the law starts propagating forced
labor on a
Saturday then it is in violation of
God's law yeah so our reason for putting
this in is to show people that there's
nothing wrong with doing the Lord's work
on a
Sunday but there is definitely something
wrong
if you are forced not to keep the
Sabbath seventh day so there's no
changing over this quote is not telling
us that you can leave Sabbath Saturday
and move over to
Sunday it's not telling us that at all
let's end with another quote which I
think is very important for the times we
are living in number one it is time for
God's people to work as never before
because of the increase of wickedness
and because of the increase of
wickedness there is this call back to
morality yeah and one of the issues is a
day of rest the church is clamoring it
for it for people to go back to
church the secular world is clamoring
for it to give you a labor day of rest
and the environmental world world is
clamoring for a day off let's make it a
synchronized day of rest then all
parties will be happy
[Music]
and then of
course we will come into conflict
because God's law is very
specific so if we continue to read here
the world is overborne with falsehood
and iniquity and Those whom God has made
the depositories of his law and of the
pure religion of Jesus must be
determined to let their light shine if
they do nothing to dis abuse the minds
of the people and through ignorance of
the truth our legislatures should abjure
the principles of
protestantism and give countenance and
support to the Roman fallacy the spous
Sabbath God will hold his people who
have had great light responsible for
their lack of diligence and
faithfulness but if the subject of
religious legislation is judiciously and
intelligent laid before the people and
they see that through Sunday enforcement
the Roman apostasy would be reenacted by
the Christian world and that the tyranny
of the past ages would be repeated then
whatever comes we shall have done our
duty Martin whatever comes we know what
is coming yeah the mark of the beast
will be enforced the Bible says
eventually it will lead to a death
penalty and those who choose
to Stand By God's Commandments will face
the ey of the devil and the ey of the
Beast and the second
beast will support him in his activity
Fallen protestantism with the power of
the United
States and we will have done our duty if
we have warned the world that's it so
please take note listeners that the
world is agitating for a law that is
contradicting ictory with the law of God
they're even so arrogant as to take one
commandment out and call it the third
commandment when we really dealing with
the fourth think about these issues whom
will we serve the Bible says they have
made void thy law it is time for thee to
work oh my God God will
intercede what side of the Divide are we
going to stand on as for me and my house
and I'm sure you and your house we will
keep the Sabbath of the Lord let's
pray Heavenly
Father we are speeding towards the final
events we are told that when these
points are being discussed it is time to
get out of the Cities because there will
be calamities such as we have have not
imagined possible until
now wake up your people and help us to
make the issue clear so that thinking
Minds can make right choices is our
prayer in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]